now I have this to show you're looking
at what's been dubbed the desert Monkey
King
see the resemblance guys it's a geoglyph
on a bluff above the Southwest Valley
look at it right there we've asked
around and no one knows who made it the
BLM is trying to figure it out too we
could tell you it's no older than five
years old you can read more on our
website atnewsnow.com I'm trying to look
and read to at the same time right am I
looking for a monkey yeah yes they're uh
middle left of your television looks
like Snoopy now it's more of the top of
your TV they're kind of there it is
Desert Snoopy I think oh yeah we all see
yeah yeah do you not see it yeah
is it a blue dress or a gold dress I
really did see it yeah Chris can you
just play the tape back for Chris guys
Brian's side yeah